all right the chris sims quarterback
countdown continues with
more being revealed we got up to marcus
mariota yesterday that means 35 tyrod
taylor 34
tua
tonga
let's start with tyrod taylor yeah
interesting career for him right he had
his moment with the buffalo bills and i
remember when he became a free agent
after four years of backing up joe
flacco in denver no not in denver
baltimore denver wanted him denver
wanted him gary kubiak wanted him gary
kubiak had the history with him in
baltimore because kubiak was there in
between coaching stints with the texans
and the broncos tyrod taylor picked the
bills became a starter won a playoff
game or no got to the playoffs didn't
win a playoff game right didn't want to
play i think they won they beat the
jacksonville jaguars in a wild card
playoff game didn't they i thought i
thought they oh no you know what they
lost you're right jaguars seven you're
right you're thirteen three you're right
you're right 10-3 yeah i think it was
yep but uh but since then it's been
you know the
starter in cleveland until he got
injured started with the chargers until
he got injured and now
if deshawn watson's not there in houston
tyrod taylor's the top guy on the depth
chart yeah period yeah until davis mills
until he gets injured until dr needle
comes walking into the locker room and
davis mills ends up being the quarter
well yeah that's exactly right i mean
tyrod taylor a lot like case keenum he's
the ultimate backup quarterback he's as
good as about you're gonna find out
there you know in the nfl as far as a
guy that can come off the bench doesn't
ever seem to blink an eye you know has
got just ice cold water in his veins
that way plus he's got some you know
some things that are really awesome
about his game you know his arm is big
time his athletic ability is pretty damn
good with his ability to throw on the
run get out of the pocket do things like
that so that's where ty rod taylor and
the value of him as a football player is
is one oh our starters down wait we got
one of the best backups in football and
two like we're seeing this year he can
be that you know
bridge gap type of quarterback for a
team that's looking for somebody for the
future
and
who knows maybe in the process has
enough talent
to maybe really hunker down and take
control
of a starting job that that's to me and
you know i said this last year you know
and that's where it stinks for tyrod
taylor because maybe he could have
answered these questions if dr needle
didn't screw his ear over last year but
the fact that
and i i don't know if you remember this
the number one negative about tyrod
taylor in my opinion is lack of
aggressiveness lack of not always taking
advantage of everything that's there to
be had in an offense all the yards all
the big pass plays he can be way too
overly conservative
and that's why he's gotten to places and
they're always like
uh we think we can do better we think we
can do better because he's got the
talent to be a really good quarterback
but he plays the position
like a man a game manager mike if that
makes sense and that's why he falls at
number 35 here for me he's probably got
more talent than than the 35th
quarterback in football
yeah look i agree it's just one of these
things where sometimes circumstances
conspire to keep a guy from
reaching right the full potential and
he's just been in these spots and he had
to
have groaned a little bit when he saw
that they drafted davis mills because it
was setting up
for tyrod taylor and it still is there's
no guarantee davis mills is going to be
ready to go he's a third round pick and
they got to develop him but
and it's not the same as having a top
six exactly or behind you like it was
with the chargers and the number one
overall pick a couple years before that
with the brown so he's he's going to get
a chance yes now who knows what the
texans are going to be this year but you
know what as expectations go
they're as low as they can be when the
betting lines came out westgate had the
betting lines for every single regular
season game all 272 of them and the
texans
were not favored to win a single game so
the bar is low anything tyrod taylor
manages to do is going to be viewed as
exceeding expectations for the texas yes
great leader you know kind of the kind
of guy that you know i i think could
handle all the circumstances around this
situation with the houston texans and
mike i think your point too with you
know who's there behind them is a little
different you know like you said oh
baker mayfield justin herbert hey i'm
the starter yeah i'm tired taylor i'm
the starter but it's like we always talk
about when you have guys like that
behind you who are physically better
than you and have a stronger arm and
things like that the guy you know guys
walk in the locker room every day going
yeah tyrod was good you see baker's
throw today do you see justin herbert
throw those lasers around the field he's
not going to have that this year so
that's going to be a positive for him
davis mills is good he's polished but he
has no
elite physical attribute that guys are
gonna walk in the locker room and go
whoa did you see that today you know so
that's where it's a good thing for tyrod
taylor to where maybe he can really
hunker down and be the starting
quarterback for this football team but
he can handle all these situations like
you said he's a playoff quarterback he's
not a superstar but there's a lot of
good things he does in his game and you
know where i'd like to see him get
better
from tyrod taylor to tuatanga viloa tua
up from number 40
in 2020 now number 34 on the chris sims
top 40 quarterback countdown you know
someone look at this and say what's he
done to climb six spots so i'll ask you
that question sure what's he done to
climb six spots well you know it's it's
another year in the nfl he won some
football games he's got experience and
you know for most of the people that
he's in in front of other than maybe
a
rod tail or a case kingdom he does have
more experience that way you know and
tua yeah there's things i'd like to see
him be physically better at you know
he's got a good arm like we talked about
but it's not a great arm there's no
doubt about that he's a good athlete
he's not a great athlete but he does
have presence and charisma and knows how
to lead a football team and do those
type of things too and we saw growth
throughout the year but yeah he's 34 and
i can't put him in the top 32 yet
because i don't know about tua totally
yet i don't you know there's a lot of
things and intangibles i like about his
game and what he does he knows how to
play the game you know he did get a
little bit more aggressive throwing the
football as the year went on but just
like the guy we just talked about you
know a minute ago and tyrod taylor
that's a part of the game that two has
got to go up that's the reason ryan
fitzpatrick was brought in so many times
they didn't run different plays with
fitzpatrick when he came in fitzpatrick
just had a more aggressive attitude and
didn't leave some of the plays and
throws and yards on the field that we
talk about that's so important to make
an offense successful so i'm expecting
big growth out of tua i am and he still
did do some good things last year even
though it wasn't top five of the draft
type good things it was enough good for
me to move him up and feel at least a
little bit better about what you know
what we saw as compared to going into
last year
and and look
there was speculation they would yes
targeted quarterback in round one when
they had the sixth pick when they had
the third pick right could they do
something along those lines and the
desean watson stuff it's still there in
a way right and and and and i think very
few
dolphins fans would bristle even those
who have paid the full freight for the
authentic tuatanga viloa jersey with the
numbers stitched on that's like 300
bucks i i think that they'd be okay
with deshaun watson because
even if tuatanga viloa develops the way
that they're all hoping he can
still not desean watson no no way never
will
he's not to sean watson and never will
be yeah no that that that's that's i
think the point and you know all that
chatter is real for all those people
that don't think it is real everything
that mike you just explained we know
that listen and and we know too
that
he didn't blow everybody out of the
water there last year with what he did
in practice we talked about that we
heard comments from you know media
people following the football team last
year in training camp and early in the
year where we heard chatter where they
were like yeah guys weren't like oh my
gosh this guy is unbelievable we got to
get him out there we heard that stuff
with justin herbert and joe burrow and
those type of and those type of guys who
have come in and like wowed people from
the get-go where you're just like
remember even josh allen lesean mccoy
was like holy cow this guy he's got
something he's got he's got skills holy
cow he's got a rifle none of that came
out of to it so that can be
underwhelming especially when you're the
number five pick of the draft but i
don't think that's his game anyways his
game is going to be about being a
wheeler and dealer he's slick in the
pocket he's got some different arm
angles he's got a good feel for the game
he's smart and he understands how to
play the game in totality uh as far as
seeing the big picture that's what he
proved to me last year too and i do
expect more aggressive decision making
and let's not forget hey he's got some
talent around him this year going into
the season you know last year again as
critical as we can be we could certainly
sit here and go they weren't the most
weapon-filled offense in football you
know they've done a lot to help him out
to maybe accentuate some of those
talents we've talked about mike and and
see where it goes from there
is it hard to evaluate a guy objectively
and dispassionately when
we just really like him isn't that hard
it's all hard it really is i i try to do
i try to block it out yeah i've been
pinned as this big to a hater you know
just because i had a guy i know but you
couldn't tell anybody on social media
that they think i have like a voodoo
doll and i'm sticking needles in his eye
but because of where i've had him ranked
and stuff like that i do i love the guy
it's the problem with this business you
can't say anything critical about
football then they think it's personal
and that does bother me and yes i have
to do a good job of blocking those
things out
now you're making me wonder who had the
voodoo doll sticking needles in your
spleen
that's that that is
multiple people could have been lots of
people let's say if if hey if that day
the fact that i'm still alive proves
that the voodoo doll does not work
you're right
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports